Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
And this video we are going to be
talking about the NFC intuitive feelers
intuitors you will notice are moderately
different compared to those sensory
counterparts. Now even though nos and NTDs
are only one fourth of the population,
I'd bet the majority of you watching this
tested and because Meyers Briggs type
psychology is a topic which
tends to attract intuitive types.
And in this video we'll be focusing
again on the NFS, the IFP, the NFP,
the I of Jay and the enf Jay.
Now you'll notice s's are divided
between perceiving and judging,
P and j whereas ends are divided
between thinking and feeling. T and f.
Y will, I'm not entirely sure why
this is the common way of doing it.
It seems unnecessary as having intuitive
perceivers and intuitive judges would
be equally sufficient.
But I will say though that even though
as you will see an J's and nps calve
considerably different
functions stack just as the SS,
how they appear on the surface and the
kind of habits, interests, lifestyles,
et cetera that they develop
are moderately similar.
So what's the big deal about
the end as divide? Well,
as usual we'll get to the cognitive
function explanation and a bed,
but for now will be sufficient to
say that like all ends and s are more
interested in sort of what if or abstract
concepts and possibilities they may
trust there in to feelings over what
their senses are telling them and they're
particularly good at reading between
the lines and information of whatever
nature or a sensors can see if things by
starting with facts and then forming a
larger picture and try to grasp the whole
picture at once and then work out the
components and like all F's feelers ns
prefer to make decisions and judge things
in accordance with the system of morals
and values which they focus on a polling
and refining throughout their lives and
will often aspire to curry conditions
which are fair and equitable for everyone
or an essence create harmony as I've
stressed feeling and Myers Briggs,
it's not equate to emotions.
Afs may have a greater focus on emotions
and in fact a better understanding of
them.
But the irony is that thinkers may at
times be worse at handling their emotions,
but more on that later and F's are
usually bright, caring, friendly,
sociable and creative people.
They will often place emphasis on human
relationships and interactions both on
the small and large scale from the
people close to them to a larger social
picture constituting the
relations of humankind.
No often place great emphasis
on ideals and values.
So the values developed by intuitive
feelers are not always necessarily in
accordance with common
or traditional values.
They will often more independently
develop an idea of how society should
interact and exist and in fact in abuse
society's values as short sighted,
shallow and a moral being particularly
critical of hypocrisy in consistency and
inauthenticity.
These traits may encourage them to be
somewhat rebellious and to become active
in movements of other conservation
of some things or a change in others.
This is not the say that they're stubborn
or and flexible like most theaters
there are generally friendly and easy
going and only become combative and
certain lines across. They do, however,
expect themselves to
adhere to these morals.
Very strongly believe that doing so is
it necessary in their quest to connect
with their inner selves or to find
their place in the world. However,
in relation to the people they care about,
they will often try to see the best and
then there will be more likely to reach
out and help them then to be accessibly
critical and order them we could say and
to shape.
However,
when stressed or otherwise unhealthy
and F's May become selfish, defensive,
argumentative,
impulsive or unreasonable,
they may switch from attempted to see
the best and others to seeing all the
negative aspects of people on society.
Seeing the core of humanity is being
shallow, helpless, and inherently corrupt.
Furthermore,
while striving for ideal relations and
circumstances is admirable and useful,
there's subjective value systems and
as IRS for other people may come into
conflict with objective facts,
which NFS may find to be cold,
robotic and inhuman in certain
situations and so usually capable of
understanding logical
reasoning and being logical,
but they may have difficulty in conflicts
in which a logical course of action is
not exactly the most moral or ideal,
especially if it affects others.
They care about. If NFC not ever
come this to may stagnate or in deer,
unnecessary pain in situations such as
unhealthy relationships or unhealthy
employment,
worse,
they may begin to solve problems and
negative ways because I know it's have a
higher sense of others'
feelings and intentions.
Then it become manipulative and coerce
others into things. Most are not though,
especially commonly in most Ns,
come to balance these traits
throughout their lives.
Often they're focused on ideals and their
skill with people and their ability to
grasp the big picture. Well, we'll
try going to subjects like philosophy,
literature, sociology,
politics, psychology, et
cetera. And as you will see,
many notable figures within these fields
throughout history have been an apps.
Now, of course, as usual, to
truly understand these types,
we have to look at the cognitive
functions beneath the surface.
So here are the four types.
Again, the IFP, the NFP,
the inf ga in the enf Jay, and here are
their associated cognitive functions.
So as you can see it, like I
said, Ns maybe similar people,
but they opt arrived for
these similarities with
fairly different decision
making preferences at perspectives.
If that makes sense.
Essentially the circuitry is a
bit different and as you can see,
no shared functions.
They're both intuitive feelers because
they're to lead functions are both
intuition and feeling, but they're
opposite focuses. Nfj Is r,
N I and Effie,
introverted intuition and extra feeling.
Well NFP is our FII and an e introverted
feeling and extroverted intuition with
their inferior functions.
Likewise of course being opposites.
And of course you see here the flip
flopping of function preferences between
introverts and extroverts
have the same type.
So I've said that there are differences,
but the question is what differences
are they? So let's break it down.
Starting with the opposite
intuition functions.
So what's the difference of the
introverted intuition of NF Ga's and the
extroverted intuition of nfps?
Well, of the four dichotomies,
the difference between an eye in any
is probably the most difficult to
understand. Maybe even the least
solid difference in Myers Briggs,
they're both functions focused on
ideas and concepts and possibilities.
But Eni function is more on connecting
concepts if it'll larger picture.
Whereas n he is a bit more like idea
generation or brainstorming sort of what
you might expect from what introverted
and extroverted seem to imply.
So I NFJ is and Ian of J's are going to
focus more on tying points together to
reach a single or a more
refined understanding of things.
Kind of like a system building process
that may just intuitively know how or why
something is the way it is.
And this may be expressed by moments
where they pause and say something like,
wait a second, I know exactly what's
going on here. Something like that.
And even though the very sociable,
they particularly I fjs may seem to
daydream a lot and seem kind of pensive.
All intuitors can be somewhat pensive
and NFJ is of course no exception needing
to sort things out in their head from
time to time, especially introverts.
And in he ifps and enf is
however is a bit more random,
not in the sense that nfps have
short attention spans or something.
Often when an NFP gets
interested in something,
they focus on it with a lot of enthusiasm,
but they do kind of jump around from
topic to topic and are very receptive to
new ideas.
So much so that they may feel
uncomfortable making up their minds about
somethings he nfps who lead with any,
especially because there's always
something new to explore or to do.
They may develop new interests and change
their hobbies within just a few months
and then come back to the much later,
which is a major contributor to why NFP
is are a little bit more bothered by
routine than NF js. They're very good at
brainstorming and ige idea generation,
as I said as well,
and then maybe focused on taking things
and trying to find new ways to do things
with them, which are perhaps
the only new original or random.
We've talked about any before as an
inferior function, but as a lead function,
nfps are usually very good at taking
in something and then asking, well,
what if we do this to it?
What if we make it like this?
How about if we change this?
Things like that.
They're very good at
playing with concepts. Now,
the difference in feeling extroverted
feeling versus introverted feeling.
We've talked about introverted feeling
leads before with the ESF p and the s and
p and it's essentially the same
function and inf fees, any NFPS,
but the way it's expressed in combination
with intuition is moderately different.
FIS is a function with sort of the
world by a system of values and morals,
which is the NFP people spend their
lives trying to connect with refine and
exhibit and themselves. They're very
aware of their sense of right and wrong.
Keep in mind though that this is a more
independent sense of right and wrong.
They may be unusually virtuous expressing
morals that much society would not,
or on the other side,
they may develop some fairly crooked
morals and be fairly disagreeable people.
They're also very aware
of their own emotions.
Even when they feel
emotional or overwhelmed,
they're usually more aware of what they're
feeling and why and are accordingly
more steady in dealing with things
and monitoring their emotions.
Whereas fes can be zero to a hundred
if particular emotions or provoked in a
certain way, but more on Effie
in a second like SFPs. NFP is,
wants to refine their morals
and act in accordance with them,
but while SFPs maybe more focused on
doing this by getting out into the world
and learning how it is,
I guess you could say nfps and combination
with any often prefer to do this with
ideas, concepts, symbols,
metaphor, et cetera.
There are a bit philosophic
and how they ponder things.
This comes out in a smaller scale.
When NFP is our explaining or arguing
that tend to use a lot of metaphors to
convey their introverted feeling,
reasoning on a larger scale, they'll,
they'll probably take interest in
things like literature, music, arts,
certain sciences, et Cetera.
Literature is a good example.
Both nfps and NFJ is can
be excellent writers,
but a very good example of the Fsi in
any combination inaction is talking and I
NFP and his books more commonly and his
movies at the Lord of the rings Middle
Earth is a wonderfully
developed fictional world.
And to credit him much more so than a
lot of popular fictional worlds of our
time. There's histories of
entire fictional civilizations.
He covers a whole history of his world
and detail. He invents languages,
things like that.
That kind of thing is at an end you
would just enjoy creating an a level of
creativity that they're fully capable of.
Looking at this story specifically,
it's full of symbolism.
Taking the one ring in particular,
I can symbolize a lot of negative traits
of humankind's such as the desire for
power to the point where
people like Gandalf for
Aragorn or l Ron feel like they
can't handle it. So the task falls on
Frodo, who is by the way, typed as an IFP,
as far as fictional characters go,
which typing fictional characters can
be awkward to do and lead to a lot of
mistakes,
but it falls on him because even though
Frodo is just this little guy from an
uninformed,
unimportant place,
he's courageous and he has unbreakable
virtue and talking obviously implies that
this is the kind of character which is
necessary for human kind of triumph over
evil, which is very, very stereotypical
of NFP writing. But anyway,
that's my nerdy tangent example. Let's
talk about Effie in the NFJ js like f. I.
F he has also expressed differently
an intuitive types and their SFJ
counterparts,
which we talked about before.
If he has a function dedicated toward a
focus on the feelings and intentions of
others. In essence, it's very
focused on people and in fact,
fes may tend to be strongly affected
by how others, especially people,
they care about our feeling to the
point where the emotions of others can
influence their emotions much
more significantly driving
them to try to help out
as accordingly.
I don't mean to be misleading here though.
This is not necessarily mean
that Nfj is are pushovers.
They may accommodate others in
certain ways but maybe very,
very adamant and their principles and
are much more likely to try to convince
people that their position or belief is
right or beneficial rather than silence
it for group harmony.
And importantly not all of them want
to be motherly caretakers who just love
everybody and if Jason May be very good
with people enf fjs in particular are
usually good at breaking the ice with
people whereas inf shades are quieter and
further smaller circles and such.
But a focus on people and increase
intuitive awareness of their emotions and
attention is not necessarily
mean a love of people.
And in fact from personal experience,
and this is just personal experience I
take with a grain of salt from the NFJ is
I know several of them have expressed
annoyance with how unpleasant the general
people general people can be and
several of them aren't even going into
professions where there'll
be working with people,
but combined with their intuitive
sense when they do work with people,
not only are they obviously good at it,
they like it to be for a higher
purpose and this is Austin.
What makes them exceptional leaders and
we can see this type of leadership in
leaders like Martin Luther King Jr,
Bernie Sanders, Gandhi, Thomas Jefferson,
et cetera.
All NF.
Jay's despite their ability to help
others are not always good with our own
emotions.
Though it may struggle with their own
feelings and maybe feel they may feel
unappreciated if their efforts going
noticed, if certain lines are crossed.
They may,
as I said,
go to zero to 100 and react very strongly
now for the difference in the thinking
functions and fjs prefer preferred.
I interpreted thinking and nfps
preferred Tki, extroverted thinking.
Tiaa is a focus on organizing
one's understanding of
the world into an internal
logical framework.
It causes people to try to consistently
refined their understanding of things
and connect them into a
sort of logical system.
In NFJ is his function is of course
often superseded by f e and an I,
but Nfj is with a
particularly strong TEI sense,
tend to enjoy logic or puzzles or math.
They may like science or technology
and they're very good at systematizing
things from the perspective of an INTP.
It's always been interesting
to me to see and I,
and t I worked together a sort of
tie in the background systemizing the
intuitions and when you combine this with
f e you may get something like all of
this Myers Briggs types in
the cognitive functions.
There is some debate over INTP or inf,
but these two types that can be actually
kind of similar on the surface too,
but a lot of people believe
that Carl Young was an Imfj.
Carl Young is of course the psychologist
who developed the cognitive functions
on which Myers Briggs types
are based. T. I also of course,
comes out when NF Ga's are
stressed or when it's encouraged,
when they're confronted and arguing
with people who are being excessively
emotional to become very logical and the
response and critical people displaying
extreme emotion for no reason,
especially if it's just
disrupting harmony and fps,
prefer a tee extroverted thinking,
which is of course focused on the
efficient organisation of the external
environment's planning, organizing,
or finding moving things, et cetera.
Even though it is of course superseded
by the more preferred functions.
This of course comes out in multiple ways.
In nfps it comes out and
how they organize things.
I may have sort of moments of enthusiasm
where they want to clean and organize
everything and get things in order.
It comes out when they're put into
leadership positions. Not all,
especially I nfps enjoy leadership,
but sometimes they do and when they do,
they made us play organizational behavior
more in accordance with how a key lead
would act.
Then an NFJ would with Evie
using extroverted thinking
to enforce her district
justification of fie to
establish an ideal order.
Essentially NFP is tend to
be very relaxed, easy going,
people who are open to suggestions,
which can cause them to be indecisive,
but when circumstances require it to,
they'll make decisions represented by a
tee and enter into a kind of TC ob mode.
Furthermore,
I can draw them to take
interest in certain things
such as engineering, sciences,
math, computers, law, et Cetera.
And is also of course a parents and
teaching and social work positions,
which nfps tend to be attracted to
when confronted with an argument and
sufficiently angry nfps will often express
FII with both any antiquey where they
may try to get to the
bottom line of things,
perhaps very adamantly and say this
is just the way that it has to be or
something like that.
And the final function is
of course sensing and be
for STI and of Shay's prefer
s e s as we focused on more in depth in
the SGA video as a function dedicated
toward associating experiences to form a
larger internal framework of why things
happen and what happens
when those things happen.
And as I is accomplished this by being
very focused on specific facts and
details about the things which take place.
Often they will use this function to
support and help develop f. I. N, N, e, I,
n fjs and Enf js prefer s.
E extroverted sensing.
So they may have a tendency to be a
little bit more athletic and coordinated.
The may enjoy sports or physical
activities somewhat more than May in
combination with Effie. Feel an urge
to go out and do things with others,
may have a fairly good sense of fashion
and they may at times be a little bit
more spontaneous or impulsive.
Now,
an NFP may be a little bit
impulsive sometimes too,
but in many situations they may take a
few seconds to make up their minds about
things,
whereas an Nfj may,
especially if encouraged to be more likely
to just jump right into something and
whether or not that is a
good thing is of course,
relative to the individual
and the situation or Clayton.
So in conclusion though,
nfps and NF Jays have
opposite function stacks.
It turned out on the surface
to be somewhat similar. People,
they're often likable, intelligent,
independent minded and caring people.
Their ability to grasp large concepts
easily and they're intuitive insight into
the functioning of the world has been
responsible for a great number of positive
and often much needed changes in human
history and their desire to improve
themselves and others
will often lead them,
fulfill the role of standard bearer or
lead or encourage others to an ideal on a
small scale such as helping a friend or
resolving a conflict at work or a larger
scale such as leading the way for an
improvement for the whole of society.
And now for some NF statistics and I've
seen general constitutes 16.4% of the u
s population.
The NFP mix up 8.1% the I NFP makes up
4.4% the enf j makes up 2.5% and the I
NFJ makes up a 1.4% with the inf Jay
being the rarest type of all famous NFP is
include Mark Twain, Alan Watts, Che
Guevara, Robin Williams, and Ellen,
the generous famous I NFP is include
Shakespeare's Yung Joc Rousseau,
had girl in Kurt Cobain and John Lennon,
famous enf. Jay is included, Cicero,
Barack Obama, Johann von
Gutta, Neil degrasse Tyson,
and Jennifer Lawrence and famous inf
Jay's include Plato and Niels Bohr,
Leon Trotsky, Marilyn
Manson, and Cate Blanchett.
So that's the intuitive
feeler is in a nutshell.
And the next video we're going
to be talking about the Aunties,
the intuitive thinkers, and we'll wrap
up the analysis videos. That may be,
we might have a few Myers
Briggs videos after that,
but that will be the last of the
analysis videos. And to catch that video,
and for more videos like that
and on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.